[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jennifer
is with us in Austin Texas hi Jennifer
how are you good good how can we
help um I wanted to find out I have been
looking for a house for about nine years
and I found one but it's kind of a
flipper and it's about $2 million so I
didn't know if it would be wise in our
situation okay let's just back up
looking for a house for 9 years is weird
let's start with
that okay we would love to build but
here in Texas they do not licensed
contractors so it's like almost
impossible to manage a project here so I
kind of have to just remodel something
and hope that it's you know we got
pretty good bones and the property's
good so um why does that why does it
take nine years to discover you need a
general contractor to build a
house
no well we um I I I won't want I do not
want to build a house here because I I
I'm in the I'm in that industry but I
don't want to have to manage a project
and their contractors here are they
they're not licensed so it's really hard
to they don't license general
contractors in Texas no I no Google it
it's insane I don't I don't really work
in Texas no it's kind of like the wild
wild west of construction I don't even
go into tall buildings here if there are
more than two floors I won't go in them
so wow yeah that's not that's not
general contractor licensing that's
engineering and that's also weird Okay
um okay so you want to you you want to
build a you want to buy a house for $2
million that you have to fix up and then
you're going to flip it love the land no
no I'm just saying like it's not a
flipper then if you're not going to flip
it it's just you're buying a house that
needs a lot of work yeah it looks like
flipper
conditions yikes why do you want to buy
this property then do you have the money
proper is beautiful well that's what I
want to talk to you about I'm not sure
cuz the way we've always purchased
houses in before before would be
completely different than this purchase
we've always saved enough cash where we
just did the tip so we wouldn't do a
jumbo loan we' do whatever the maximum
was like our first house was like 417 I
think now it's up to like 500 and
something for like before you go to a
jumbo loan and then we put cash down and
then do a 15-year mortgage and do 20%
down and that's the way we've always
bought our houses but this one just
because I don't think we have enough I I
think the payment would be too high
because the interest rates are so high
right now that we wouldn't I think we
would have to do like a 20 or 30y year
mortgage oh so you're what you're saying
is you just can't afford the
house I I it's okay to say that out low
Jennifer it's a $2 million house I know
well that well
we yeah what is your income what's the
household
income together are BAS salaries is
about 520 okay and the thing is the
reason we don't have a lot of money
saved is because normally we don't work
both at the same time but just since
I've been working a lot more the last
few years I've enjoyed it so now I'm
working all the time he's working um I
do Global architecture so um
architecture and interior design not
really I do work for an engineering an
IT company but uh it's construction
engineering so I I do but I work for an
it company building their their
facilities all over the US the the so
your household income is
$525,000 and why can't you put a $2
million house on a 15E because we've
really been living beyond our well not
beyond our means we live within our
means but like we spent a lot of our
savings like my husband took two years
off during coid and we remodeled our
house and we just did about a I bought a
house from my daughter we just like
spent a lot of money and we normally
have more savings don't have what was
that I said I'm tired this is y'all
you've been running million miles an
hour with nothing to show for it oh my
gosh yeah so we well we've never really
had this much income steadily we've had
it for the last few years okay if you've
had it for two years or more you can
qualify for a 15-year mortgage and you
can afford a 15-year mortgage I think we
could no I know that we could qualify
for a 15year mortgage quy for that no no
okay sorry I sorry I didn't mean to say
that I just don't want our house payment
to be that high because I know my
husband will be against that so that's
why I want to do like a 30 until the 20
or a 30 until the interest rates are
lower no you take out a 15 and when the
interest rates are lower you
refinance and if you're not willing to
admit that you're buying a $2 million
house to your husband you shouldn't buy
a $2 million house um so I can't make
this not be not be $2 million there's
not a technique for that it's $2
million and um I I got a I got a feeling
your husband doesn't want to do a $2
million fixer upper either so I think
there's probably more going on and
you've kind of gotten this romantic idea
that this land is beautiful and it makes
this whole project
worthwhile um I I don't know if if you
guys together want to sit down and look
at
the trouble and the pain that doing a
remodel is going to be that you're going
to live in which is way different than
doing one that you're not going to live
in that's a lot of pain it's a lot of
Heartache it's like building a house
except
worse um you remodels are just horrid
and uh I've done a bunch of them and
they're just even when you're not going
to live in them they're a pain in the
butt it's easier to push it down start
again um and then um emotionally easier
for sure if you guys want to endure the
pain of that you have the financial
wherewithal to do it and you're willing
to accept the reality of the payment
that a $2 million loan takes on both of
you you and your husband then go forward
but I got a feeling that there's in that
in those guidelines I just gave you that
you all are going to run into all kinds
of trouble and you're just you're
wanting somebody to tell you you can't
afford it um I think you can afford it I
just don't think you want to afford it
that's what I heard what' you hear well
I'm hearing a lot of stress and I don't
know that this $2 million mortgage is
going to alleviate any of that and so
they need to simplify their life get
their act together figure out how to
control the money that they're bringing
in but would pause on this decision it
does not sound like they're close to
alignment all over the place like and
there's also I don't know million dooll
houses in Austin that are great so maybe
we could start there it doesn't have to
be the two million or bust so I think we
have to back out and find out what all
of the options are before we get star it
at one yeah
um and I'll just go ahead and throw in
here too um just just to be straight
with you Jennifer the idea that everyone
in Texas that lives in a home or has a
three-story building is incompetent and
all of them are about to fall in because
they don't license gc's is absurd okay
obviously there's quality buildings in
Texas that are not going to fall in um
and obviously I did not know they didn't
license gc's but that didn't change
anything for me there's I've been in a
bunch of houses in Texas that are
wonderful properties and you're so brave
yeah I'm brave you went to the third
floor and everything I did I've been to
the 16th floor on I mean it's scary you
know not not in a house but I mean golly
come on girl seriously